there have been movements and
organization taking place for months now
probably more than a year to get people
ready to immediately take to the streets
if Donald Trump fires special prosecutor
Robert Muller now that the New York
Times has reported that deputy AG rod
Rosenstein supposedly considered
secretly reporting Trump and using the
25th amendment to remove Trump from
office and indeed we learned just an
hour ago that deputy AG rod Rosenstein
is leaving he's either resigning has
been forced to resign or has been fired
you probably will know by the time you
watch this even though we don't yet know
right now it is time for the activation
of the more than 400,000 Americans in
more than 900 cities who have already
signed up to take to the streets in
protest if indeed the next level of
interference with the Trump
administration with the Trump Russia
organiz investigation takes place and
remember I said earlier that the story
about Rosenstein in the New York Times
could well be true and also its timing
or leak could have been orchestrated by
the right in order to create a pretext
for rod Rosenstein to leave his position
which is exactly what has happened
whatever the real number of people is
who are ready to take to the streets in
protest it could be four hundred
thousand maybe it's four million I mean
not everybody who's going to protest
says I'm gonna sign up online to protest
right I have been saying for a long time
that signing petitions and calling your
elected officials is fine I encourage it
but when it gets real the way it's
getting right now it's gonna take more
than change.org petitions to change this
to change things and to change what's
going on and not only protesting will be
necessary
civil disobedience is going to be
necessary even the possibility of
general strikes are going to be
necessary I want to be clear for me
civil disobedience doesn't mean violent
protests I am NOT calling for violence
there are some who say civil
disobedience includes more violent acts
I'm not saying that I am saying civil
disobedience as a collective concerted
effort of citizens to
obey certain laws or demands or orders
or commands from the institution of
power whether it's a government or a
military in our case in the United
States it's a government general strikes
are when workers in many industries in
most industries in all industries will
say we are not working in order to bring
the economy or an industry to a halt in
protest until our grievances are
addressed now here's what you have to
understand and I know that there are
people in the audience who get this
because they write to me about it
by design the vulture capitalism that we
have in the United States is set up to
prevent civil disobedience and general
strikes the way it works is as follows
employees have almost no power they need
to work to have health care because of
the system that we have wages have been
stagnant in real terms for 40 years
forty percent of Americans I think can't
cover a $400 emergency or some crazy
number we did a story about that don't
remember the exact numbers so basically
you have a situation where no one can
afford to strike or to do civil
disobedience and risk missing days at
work if you have a job and that is what
is missing from people who are furious
with immigrants for taking their jobs
right employers and corporations and
lobbyists they've set up a system that's
brilliant for them right they own you
and then you get mad at people who are
just looking for work instead of getting
mad at the sources of power that have
actually put this system in place so I
know that people are gonna write to me
and say David it's a position of
privilege to be able to strike from your
job or to do civil disobedience that's
why people go to the women's March for
two hours and then you get back to your
life and you go back to your job the
next day that's why the women's March
was on a weekend and things continue so
I get it I understand that the system is
designed to make it really inconvenient
and difficult for people to actually get
out there and protest and to do civil
disobedience and to organize general
strikes I'm merely saying to you
especially with the departure of rod
Rosenstein now and what as Pat said in
the last door
is probably gonna be a relatively muted
reaction from the public it's going to
take more to really change things and
the forces of power the forces in power
are organized so that you opt just to
stay home and look at social media and
watch reality shows and just go to work
the next day because you can't afford to
do anything else I don't have the answer
this is a very complicated situation but
I think we knew from the beginning that
if it really came to a head if the
interference in the Trump Russia
investigation really escalated it wasn't
ever obvious that there would be the
level of unrest and reaction and anger
that would be necessary to prevent Trump
from successfully interfering I hope I'm
wrong Pat I hope I'm wrong and I hope
that this really does trigger
significant protests and we say this
simply cannot happen we are gonna bring
the economy to a halt until our
grievances are addressed here because
this is simply not fair
but the system is designed for that not
to happen well hey I'm gonna take the
streets right now engage in some civil
disobedience yeah consequences be damned
where there will be no show for the next
month because Pat is going to be leaving
to engage in civil disobedience and and
participating in a general strike I want
to hear from you about this okay I hope
that you're following the show on
Instagram at David Pakman show I hope
that you're following me on Instagram at
David Pakman because we want to hear
from you about this issue and about what
you think should happen quick break back
after this today's program is sponsored
in part by zip recruiter there are job
sites that send you tons of the wrong
resumes to sort through or make you wait
for the right candidates to apply to
your job that is not smart but what is
smart is going to zip recruiter comm
slash Pakman to hire the right person
because zip recruiter doesn't depend on
candidates finding you it finds them for
you it's powerful matching technology
scans thousands of resumes identifies
people with the right skills education
and experience for your job and actively
invites them to apply so you end up with
qualified candidates quickly no more
sorting through the wrong resume
no more waiting for the right candidates
to apply and that's why zip recruiter is
rated number one by employers in the
u.s. from hiring sites on trust pilot
with over a thousand reviews and right
now our viewers and listeners can try
zip recruiter for free by going to zip
recruiter comm slash Pakman that is zip
recruiter comm /p a que ma n one more
time
zip recruiter comm slash Pakman to try
it for free